in the cold darkness of the early
morning tens of thousands of devotees
trekked to the hilltop temple of mata
vaishnodevi an indian-administered
kashmir
at about 3 am there was a surge in the
crowd witnesses describe a horrifying
crush and people trampling over bodies
it's a tragedy many people are dead
initial reports suggest an altercation
between groups visiting the shrine
perhaps to offer special prayers for the
new year but security has also been
called into question
the police were very irresponsible they
did not put up dividers in the area
outside the cave they mixed also those
coming out of the shrine and those going
in i saw it with my own eyes police
pushed the pilgrims and also waved
battens and blew whistles to intimidate
them which spread panic and there was a
stampede in no time
mata vaishna devi shrine is one of
india's most revered hindu sites before
the pandemic about a hundred thousand
devotees would climb the steep winding
track every day to the narrow cave
containing the shrine
authorities had kept the daily number at
25 000 but witnesses suggest many more
people were there
somewhere there was mismanagement when
we knew that there was this type of rush
we should have stopped the public first
if we'd stopped them earlier this
tragedy would not have happened
an investigation is underway into what
sparked the crush while the injured and
families of victims have been offered
compensation
deadly stampedes are fairly common
during indian religious festivals as
large crowds gather in small areas often
with few safety or crowd control
measures
[Music]
i express my condolences to the families
who have lost their dear ones and the
sad incident of the stampede my
sympathies to those who are injured
access to the shrine was halted for
several hours but later resumed
alexi o'brien al jazeera